وخلال وقفه احتجاجيه وسط العاصمه ندى احمد
نجيب الشاب رئيس جبهه الخلاص باحاله
السياسيين ومحامين وحقوقينا
وصحفيين الى التحقيق دون موجي بحق وبسبب
انتقادهم للسلطه حسب تعبيره
تدافع عن الثوره وتسعى الى استعاده الحريه
لمجتمع يتميز بالتنوع
[تصفيق]
الصور نتبعها اذن من تونس وتبدو هنالك
المجموعات في طريقها الى شارع الحبيب
بورقيبه حيث من المنتظر ان تحيي هذه
الجماهير الذكرى الثانيه عشر للثوره بعد
ما همم انطلقت بمسيره كنا نتابع رئيس جبهه
الخلاص وهو يطالب برحيل مع الجموع طبعا
برحيل الرئيس قيس سعيد ويتحدث كما قلنا عن
ضروره استعاده الحريه والحفاظ على
التنوع في همم الشقه المتعلق بالاجراءات
التي وصفت بتفرد الرئيس التونسيه بها
وتفردده بالح